this episode is sponsored by wandrium
watch until the end of the video to find
out more the discovery of the nag hamadi
library in 1945 is along with the Dead
Sea Scrolls one of the most significant
archaeological discoveries of the 20th
century it gave us writings from some of
the earliest Christians writings that
were not included in the eventually
canonized New Testament and which gave
us unprecedented insight into some of
these early movements that we previously
only knew from second hand often
critical accounts it is for example in
these writings that we now have access
to the writings of these so-called
gnostics as well as many other groups
now one of the most famous maybe the
most famous and mysterious texts from
the nag hamadi library is the so-called
Gospel of Thomas a book that often
defies any clear association with the
known groups of early Christianity and
which includes some really sometimes
surprising sayings from Jesus
[Applause]
the canonical New Testament that we all
know and love include four gospels
Matthew Mark Luke and John they serve as
the basis for information about the life
sayings and teachings of Jesus to
Christians around the world but as most
of us know there were many other gospels
and accounts as well
the canonization process was a gradual
one but really solidified around the 4th
Century before this time and in the
after there existed many other gospels
and accounts of Jesus's life and
teachings which were favored by other
groups than those that became known as
quote-unquote Orthodox and one of these
is the fascinating Gospel of Thomas
which offers some teachings of Jesus
that seem very odd in comparison to the
synoptic gospels even to sometimes
contradict them indeed this is a gospel
that seems to have a pretty radically
different Theology and which was likely
favored by a group of early Christians
quite different from the proto-orthodox
so what's going on with this text the
Gospel of Thomas is kind of just that a
gospel it is an account of Jesus of
Nazareth or Jesus Christ but it differs
pretty drastically from the gospels that
we know in fact Thomas is not an account
of Jesus's life that gives us any
biographical information in instead it
is simply a collection of sayings that
Jesus conveyed to his disciples indeed
the whole gospel begins with the words
quote these are the hidden sayings that
the living Jesus spoke and Judas Thomas
the twin recorded
what follows is basically a list of
sayings 114 in total without any sort of
context or biographical material
but the courts themselves are really
fascinating for various reasons many of
these sayings we recognize from the
canonical gospels but many others are
totally unique as an example we all
recognize sayings like what you see the
speck that is in your sibling's eye but
you do not see the beam that is in your
own eye which is the 26th saying in
Thomas but can also be found in the
gospels of Matthew and Luke
so what's in this gospel first of all we
can address the question whether or not
it is a so-called Gnostic Gospel which
is how it has been oftened characterized
if we talk about the Gospel of Thomas
many people will say that this is the
most famous agnostic gospel so-called
but is this actually accurate it is true
that it was found at nag hamadi among a
bunch of books that can certainly be
labeled as Gnostic but this situation is
in fact quite complicated if you've seen
my earlier episode about the gnostics
you will know that there is a huge
debate over whether or not this term can
be used at all as a designation for a
movement in antiquity
early Christianity was an explosion of
different ideas and tendencies and it's
difficult to talk about any specific
quote-unquote groups or coherent
movements as such but we have certain
doctrinal Tendencies and schools of
thought in this period which are often
associated with so-called gnosticism and
which have certain characteristics in
particular as David brachi argues the
group that is often referred to as the
sethians is perhaps the group that can
most rightfully be referred to as the
gnostics other groups like The
valentinians and marcinats will also
often be labeled as gnostics because
they hold similar ideas but there is a
huge scholarly debate about this term if
it can be used at all if it should be
used who should it who should be applied
to and so on it's a difficult topic and
if you want to know more about that you
should advise my earlier episode about
the gnostics so is the Gospel of Thomas
part of that Gnostic movement well it's
very uncertain the sayings in Thomas
contain very little reference to the
characteristic doctrines of the gnostics
such as an ignorant demiurge as the
creator of the world or the concept of
the barbello as a first Eon or principle
now this has led some Scholars to argue
when I tend to agree with them that
Thomas is not necessarily A Gnostic
Gospel or shouldn't be called agnostic
gospel but represents another
theological tendency entirely in the
early diversity of Christianity it has
some affinities with the teachings of
the canonical gospels as well as some
similarities with the Gnostic schools
but also differ in unique ways of its
own from both of them indeed the Gospel
of Thomas fundamentally differs from Key
teachings of mainstream Christianity in
Christianity as we know it Jesus is the
Incarnation of the word of God which
brings salvation to humanity by dying on
the cross for our sins
but in the Gospel of Thomas the death
and crucifixion of Jesus is never even
mentioned it's not an important aspect
of this theology at all
Jesus does not bring Salvation through
his death instead when we read Thomas it
becomes clear that it is the very
teachings of Jesus and the following of
those teachings that will lead the
person to Salvation by gaining knowledge
of his true self
the first saying in the gospel goes like
this quote and he said whoever discovers
the interpretation of these sayings will
not taste death
in the teachings of Thomas us humans
don't belong to this material world and
body our true home and true nature is in
the spiritual world of wholeness we can
attain salvation by getting true
knowledge or gnosis of our essential
reality or our true selves and Jesus is
the figure who helps us discover this
Jesus represents the divine presence and
wisdom speaking to us reminding us of
who we really are he comes from the
spiritual world of unity our true home
to save us from this illusory material
existence
quote I am the one who comes from what
is whole I was given from the things of
my father
Jesus said I disclose my Mysteries to
those who are worthy of my mysteries in
fact the Gospel of Thomas seems to
reveal a theology where the imminence of
God is emphasized Jesus or God is
present everywhere at all times quote
Jesus said I am the light that is over
all things I am all from me all has come
forth and to me all has reached split a
piece of wood I am there lift up the
stone and you will find me there
God or Jesus is the light that in some
sense is all things he is present
everywhere including in the human self
thus Jesus calls us to know his words
and to know him as that reality and
through that knowledge know ourselves
to know God is to know yourself and vice
versa
in some way we become Jesus or God when
we turn away from darkness and towards
the light that is hidden within us quote
Jesus said whoever drinks from my mouth
will become like me I myself shall
become that person and the hidden things
will be revealed to that person this is
pretty different from at least most
interpretations of mainstream
Christianity we aren't saved because
Jesus dies on the cross but because he
teaches us to know ourselves and to know
him as the light that is present in all
existence through that self-knowledge of
ourselves and even such a core feature
of Jesus's teachings like the kingdom of
heaven or the kingdom of God is given
radically different interpretations in
the Gospel of Thomas while the canonical
gospels and Orthodox Christianity in
general seem to indicate that the
kingdom of God or the Kingdom of Heaven
is an event that is coming in the future
Jesus tells his disciples to get ready
for this event when all people will be
judged by God and the new Divine era
will be inaugurated this is not only not
present in Thomas it is outright
rejected the kingdom of God is not
coming in the future and neither is it a
place at all instead Jesus tells us that
the kingdom is already here it's
everywhere and within us this
interpretation is not unheard of in
Christianity of course but it is more
explicit in Thomas in one of the most
famous sayings from the gospel Jesus
says quote if your leaders say to you
look the kingdom is in heaven then the
birds of heaven will precede you if they
say to you it is in the sea then the
fish will precede you rather the kingdom
is inside you and it is outside you when
you know yourselves then you will be
known and you will understand that you
are the children of the living father
but if you do not know yourselves then
you will dwell in poverty and you are
poverty
this quote which comes at the very
beginning of the text kind of summarizes
the entire message and Theology of the
Gospel of Thomas the kingdom is already
here within us and within all things
it's not that it's coming and we need to
prepare it has already arrived but
people can't see it at least those
people that haven't received Jesus's
real message and at the end of the text
it kind of circles back and seals the
deal that it's a nice sort of Full
Circle when he says quote
his disciples said to him when will the
kingdom come
Jesus says it will not come by watching
for it rather the father's kingdom is
spread out upon the Earth and people do
not see it as you can tell this is a
truly unique and fascinating
interpretation of Jesus and his
teachings and it really shows us how
diverse and varied early Christianity
was there were many different groups or
tendencies that were in dialogue and
sometimes also in conflict with each
other Thomas represents one of those
tendencies that did not become part of
the later Orthodoxy but luckily we now
have access to this text for example
which gives us fasting insights into
this particular if you could call our
school of thought or a theological
tendency or whatever it is whatever this
text represents right we now can access
it at least somewhat from this text
which is just so amazing it's probably
the most famous non-canonical gospel in
the world and perhaps for good reason
given how amazing the interesting its
contents are but because of this there
are also many let's say less than
scholarly interpretations and claims
made about it there's a big debate about
when it was written and its relationship
with the other gospels some claiming
that it's the earliest source for
Jesus's sayings and that the other
gospels Drew inspiration from it but
what do we actually know about this text
from a historical scholarly perspective
well we aren't perhaps all that
surprised to learn that there really
isn't much in terms of a consensus we
have known about a Gospel of Thomas for
a long time since some of the early
church fathers mentioned it in their
writings for example the famous
Christian philosopher origin of
Alexandria mentioned it in one of his
writings quote the church has four
gospels Heretics have very many I know
one Gospel called according to Thomas
and another according to Matthias we
have read many others too lest we appear
ignorant of anything because of those
people who think they know something if
they have examined these gospels he is
all obviously not a fan of the supposed
Gospel of Thomas which could be
referring to the text we had talked
about today but might also refer to the
so-called infancy Gospel of Thomas which
has an annoyingly similar name
regardless the discovery of the text at
nag hamadi has revolutionized our
understanding of it it only survives in
one Coptic copy dating from the early
4th century
but Scholars are fairly certain that the
original text itself probably written in
Greek originates much further back
in fact basically no one would say that
the text was composed any later than the
year 200 but aside from this Scholars
disagree greatly we simply don't know
for sure when Thomas Was Written the
historians and biblical Scholars
sometimes fall into two general camps
those who adhere to an early composition
and those who believe in a late
composition or later composition I guess
some those of the first Camp believed
that Thomas was composed in the first
century around the same time that the
four canonical gospels came to be some
argue that it might even have been
earlier than them others and I would
probably say the majority of Scholars
today but keep in mind that there's
nothing in terms of a consensus here but
probably the majority of Scholars today
argue that the text was actually
composed in the early second century so
a few decades after the four you know
John Mark Matthew and Luke right but
again no complete agreement exists here
right many scholars and historians do
tend to believe that it was written much
earlier in the first century sometime
some even believe that it was earlier
like I said earlier than the canonical
gospels before the year 70 we're
obviously not going to solve this issue
today so if you're interested in diving
into the history of the manuscripts and
the different scholarly opinions about
the dating of this text then you should
check out some of the dedicated research
and always as always leave some sources
and links in the description if you want
to check that out but this topic is of
course significant because it has
implications in terms of the
relationship of Thomas to the other
gospels as we saw many of the sayings in
Thomas correspond to these sayings in
the synoptic gospels almost around half
of them in fact so the question becomes
did Thomas use the other gospels as a
source for these sayings or was it the
other way around
alternatively which Christians would of
course argue do they all perhaps
represent actual sayings of Jesus that
were preserved independently in both
texts opinions about who we influence to
will of course change depending on when
you believe that the Gospel of Thomas
was composed so if you believe that it
was composed before or at the same time
as the canonical gospels then maybe
you'll will be of the opinion that
Thomas influenced them whereas if it was
written after in the early 2nd Century
then obviously an argument could be made
for the fact that Thomas might be
drawing from these synoptic gospels so
you know it's hard to say it's all very
enticing and fascinating to think about
who was inspired by who and which if any
of these sayings actually go back to
Jesus at the very least it does tell us
that texts that were written roughly at
the same time came to represent Jesus
and sometimes the very sayings of Jesus
in radically different ways which again
shows us just how diverse and varied the
world of early Christianity really was
it is a vast and Incredibly fascinating
and complicated topic a one that is
worth diving into and one really good
way of doing that is through today's
sponsor wandrium
wandrium is an online learning platform
that brings you a vast library of
educational and engaging content through
short form videos long-form courses
tutorials documentaries and much more
they have some wonderful courses and
lectures led by experts in their
respective fields and always with really
high production quality wandrum is the
first ever sponsor here on let's talk
religion and for good reason I obviously
love to learn and study new things and
I've personally used bonjour myself and
been very happy with it I do feel like
they have the same goal as us here on
the channel to be a source for Reliable
and high quality content that is both
educational and entertaining so I'm
actually very happy to be collaborating
with them one gym has recently changed
their name from The Great Courses plus
and they are always evolving and
expanding their content ranging from
lecture series to documentaries there is
a huge library to pick from for example
if you want to learn more about the the
topic that we have talked about today
there's a great course called gnosticism
from nag hamadi to the Gospel of Judas
led by The Scholar David bracky a
professor of history at Ohio State
University and one of the world's
foremost experts in topics like
gnosticism the chorus has two whole
lectures dedicated to the Gospel of
Thomas in particular which was a big
inspiration for this episode I remember
watching those episodes a few years back
and being really surprised about what
the gospel was saying and that this
wasn't some kind of new age
interpretation but actually accepted by
scholarship if you're interested in
history which I have to assume you are
if you're watching this then there's
also a new documentary series called
traveling the Roman Empire where Darius
Arya takes you on a tour through the
Roman Empire with some beautiful footage
of the actual sites I've really enjoyed
the content that is available here and
I'm pretty sure that you will too so if
you're interested in signing up then
you're in luck because one dream is
offering a wonderful free trial if you
head over to rondrium.com let's talk
religion or click the link in the
description thank you to Adrian for
sponsoring this video thank you to
everyone for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
thank you